are we excited about the new sex and the
city spin-off and just like that uh yeah
just like that full disclosure i am a
miranda fully a miranda okay i'm carrie
okay listen i'm totally carried i can
see that she is definitely careful you
are
samantha yes
i love it well sarah jessica parker just
dropped big news a release date oh my
goodness finally
it's sarah jessica hello from new york
city fifth avenue shooting as we speak
the next chapter of sex and city
the 29 second teaser for the sex and the
city reboot was racking up more than 52
000 views an hour sjp revealing the 10
episode series will air in december i
would like to see where carrie and big
are right now i'd like to see
where all of them are i'm curious
so far we'd only seen tiny snippets of
carrie and big being romantic this new
footage of the three leading ladies was
posted two weeks to the day co-star
willie garson passed away from
pancreatic cancer he had reprised his
role along with his fellow castmates
on-screen bows but now several newcomers
are bringing diversity and girl power
sarah jessica parker is
everything you think
nicole ari parker plays lisa todd wexley
a park avenue mom of three and a
documentarian according to hubby boris
kojo she is not replacing kim catrell
she plays a completely new completely
different character uh has nothing to do
with samantha in any way i'm star struck
every day
on set and in the clothes
oh my god
just my fittings alone like
bags
and shoes
and bracelets does she have good fashion
she has great fashion
co-star karen pittman is dr naya wallace
a colombian law professor the show
really is a love letter to women is so
great to be a part of it
[Music]